it is seven o'clock which means you're
watching sky news breakfast we're living
in days of fakes and lies that
from president putin's spokesman bluntly
denying accusations of war crimes in
butcher in an exclusive interview with
sky but there was a moment of candor too
from dmitry peskov he admitted the
russian forces have suffered significant
losses in the war in ukraine also a
warning from president zielinski that
worse atrocities could yet be discovered
i'll be speaking to the chair of the
defense select committee tobias ellwood
in a few moments also the ukrainian
ambassador to the uk there is friday the
8th of april
president putin's spokesman admits that
russia has suffered significant losses
in the war with ukraine
but he bluntly denies accusations of war
crimes
the situation is butchered is a
well-staged
insinuation nothing else
ukraine's president says further worse
atrocities are coming to light
unpleasant smears the chancellor defends
his wife's tax affairs
insisting she pays every penny oath in
the uk
the fourth deadly attack in a month as
another shooting in israel leaves at
least two people dead
an easter holiday headache warnings of
long delays
as dover council says it could declare a
major incident if the gridlock continues
and it's one of the sporting highlights
of the year i'll be taking a look at
some of the names who made the cut for
tomorrow's grand national
also ahead on the program
as the academy brings forward its annual
meeting to discuss possible sanctions
for will smith after that slap at the
oscars i'll be speaking to the
entertainment broadcaster caroline frost
about what action they could take
and i'll be speaking to a former prison
officer turned author about his
experiences inside one of britain's most
notorious prisons and how they inspired
his new book
[Music]
morning all vladimir putin's spokesman
has
dismissed accusation of russian war
crimes in ukraine as fakes and lies in
an exclusive interview with sky news he
insisted that the atrocities seen in
butcher were a well staged insinuation
well the claims have been widely
dismissed with a warning from the
ukrainian president that worse is yet to
come well let's take a look at the
claims made by dmitry petrov
uh
well mr peskov admitted that russia's
military has suffered significant losses
he said the death of troops was a huge
tragedy
he went on to say that the kremlin hopes
to reach its goals in the coming days
including to liberate the city of
mariupol part of the lehansk people's
republic which russia and russia alone
recognizes as a separate state
he also dismissed verified footage
appearing to show dead ukrainian
civilians killed by russian forces as
fake
claiming the situation in butcher was a
well-staged insinuation
mr peskov denied that russian troops
have committed any war crimes during
their invasion of ukraine
saying that russia does not support or
recognize the international criminal
court let's just take a closer look at
what he said to my colleague mark austin
you've lost thousands of troops how many
troops have you lost we have we have we
have significant losses of troops and uh
it's it's it's a huge tragedy for us
here we see a woman
with a bike named today as arena filkina
walking along uh yabalanska street when
russian troops were in control
around the corner is an armored vehicle
identified by our team
as a russian military
vehicle so the russians are there you
can see the vehicle fire a shot which
creates a plume of smoke exactly
where arena was standing with her bike
after the russians have withdrawn this
video geolocated to the exact same spot
showed arena lying
dead on the ground so there can be no
real doubt surely that this
uh shows russian troops killing a
civilian yeah it's right i appreciate it
people are more specific i'll appreciate
if you could be more specific how could
you exactly identify the russian tank or
whatever what was this why do you think
it was russian okay well i think we
got a still that shows the russian tower
you can see if you look at that you can
see the v marking
clearly on the side but those are not
the tanks that we're shooting that
suggests
different positions they are they are
the exact same
uh
armored vehicles that were on that
street i mean look we've if we've
verified what you're showing right now
what you're showing right now are not
the exact tank
that was shooting
you have to be very careful you have to
be very careful in what you are showing
just not exactly the same armored
vehicle i mean
so you deny that that happened you're
denying it's happened and you're saying
it's being faked basically it's some
sort of conspiracy is that right
we deny that russian military uh can
have something in common with these
atrocities and with dead bodies that
were shown on the streets of butcher
you mentioned mario paul is part of it's
part of ukraine are you determined to
take mario pole whatever the human cost
whatever the cost in civilian life
mariopol is going to be
liberated from
nationalistic battalions
and we hope it will happen sooner than
later
uh well russia may be denying their
involvement in atrocities but as times
and cities are liberated by ukrainian
forces further horrors aren't revealing
themselves ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has described the scenes in the
town of borojanka as significantly more
dreadful than in butcher
russia has had nothing to do with the
concept of human rights for a long time
already
maybe someday that will change but so
far the russian state and the russian
military are the greatest threat on the
planet to freedom to human security to
the concept of human rights as such
after butcher this is already obvious
and as the work on dismantling the
debris in borrowed yanka began it's much
worse there
even more victims of the russian
occupiers
let's speak to our correspondent jason
joining us from the southern ukrainian
city of odessa jason good to see you i
mean worse than butcher i mean how much
do we know about what's happened or what
is alleged to have happened in borrowed
yanka
well boardian care is about 40
kilometers north west of keefe and uh
journalists haven't got there yet so we
can't verify anything that has been said
by president zielenski we've only got
his word for it um
but he sounds like he's saying that it's
matching what journalists have seen in
european and butcher
where civilians appear to have been
executed shot in the street
tortured reports of women being raped
he's saying that it's almost as if uh
it's like a tidal wave isn't it that's
receding and as the waters uh retract
the horrors are uncovered and uh that is
what it appears like as we're slowly
pushing back
and seeing what's left behind from the
russian invasion
it does appear to be
war crimes in these towns and cities
and it was interesting i watched the
interview last night of peskov with a
professor of international relations
here in odessa and his take was that
watching what he was saying about russia
feeling under threat by nato that was
something that he truly believes to be
the case
but he wasn't convinced that he believed
even he believed what he was saying
about the war crimes uh in these towns
around kiev uh it felt unconvincing to
him and here in odessa this is this is a
a russian leading community a lot of
people here speak russian they're
sympathetic with moscow but that has
changed uh over the last few weeks and i
think that's the problem for the kremlin
that if they were thinking that there
were people here sympathetic to them if
they were thinking that this was some
kind of liberation exercise this isn't
playing out well they don't really care
what we think uh in the west
but what do the people think here in
places uh like odessa uh in places like
the donbass well certainly from the
people i've spoken to here they're not
impressed
they don't believe uh what they're
hearing from the kremlin they do believe
that war war crimes are being committed
and also the soldiers that are returning
here from odessa from places like her
song which is russian occupied
about 90 kilometers down the southern
coast here uh they're saying they're
saying the same thing uh civilians dead
on the street uh russian atrocities
being committed there so that is uh the
problem that the kremlin faces at the
moment
jason many thanks indeed
well just on uh that which jason was
talking about the the efforts to secure
civilian uh civilian lives ukraine
pressing on uh with efforts to try and
rescue those uh within mario paul the
ukrainian government telling us actually
in the last few minutes that it aims to
establish as many as 10 humanitarian
corridors to mario paul but
civilians trying to flee the besieged
city may have to use private vehicles
rather than vehicles being uh deployed
by the ukrainian government we'll keep
an eye on that and more on it as we get
it but let's
bring in the chair of the house of
commons defence select committee tobias
ellwood regular on the program mr allen
good to see you once again um
you will have seen the words um of
dmitry peskov the spokesman for vladimir
putin yesterday first and foremost your
reaction to what he said to mark austin
uh yeah firstly well done for sky to
securing that interview it's important
for us to hear the diet of news that the
russian people
are experiencing
we as you reported must brace ourselves
i think for more horrors to be revealed
uh more war crimes be exposed as russian
troops uh withdraw but the spokesperson
dimitri prescott was very very clear
this is far from over and there is
another dark chapter soon to follow so
there are some big questions for nato
and the west our confidence is no doubt
building uh we're improving on our
decision-making to take risk but i make
it very very clear there's so much more
we need to do we continue to leave
ukraine to do all the heavy uh lifting
we need to provide greater weapon
systems and stop having simply daft
arguments about whether weapon systems
are indeed defensive or offensive what's
going to happen next as far as i can see
it is a focus on russia in the donbass
region and indeed in odessa and odessa
is a critical port in the south if that
falls ukraine will become landlocked the
vital grain exports that we all depend
on will not be able to get out but more
importantly putin will be able to
declare a win what we should take away
from that peskov interview is the fact
that putin is very secure in his job
he's not scared of any war crimes he's
not scared of breaching the geneva
conventions in fact he's taken advantage
of the west's timidity we've given him
space to conduct these horrors and that
needs to stop
if mr ellwood and certainly i'm not
disagreeing with there's plenty of
evidence that vladimir putin is uh is no
fan of the geneva convention but if
there is a risk of him you know breaking
once again the geneva convention is this
the time
for britain and others to therefore be
supplying that that heavier those
heavier armaments those heavier
munitions that ukrainians are calling
out for i mean the reason we didn't up
until this point the re the stated
reason was well there were concerns
about
russia declaring as becoming a party to
the war itself
you know we need to have better
confidence and understanding of the
escalatory ladder as we did during the
cold war what we can do in the theater
of operations in ukraine to support
ukraine
aware that we need to control this and
not as people are too worried about uh
causing world war three but we've been
too easily spooked by the kremlin
rhetoric britain has done more i have to
say than most other countries than i
think in nearly every other country
firstly prior to the invasion and then
after the invasion as well but
because nato itself won't give the
blessing won't endorse uh greater
hardware to be put in we're now seeing a
public bidding war the team between
countries like the slovak republic
putting in the the tanks uh poland
wanting to put in mig aircraft australia
now sending in ap apc's and indeed
britain as well this shouldn't be done
in the public gates this should be
quietly uh done behind the scenes
understanding the need of the ukrainian
people getting the equipment getting the
ammunition getting that across we're
doing enough right now to ensure that
ukraine doesn't lose but not enough to
ensure that they win let's get on with
this let's be more robust in standing up
to russia in ukraine and let's focus on
what they need to protect odessa they
need harpoon missile systems uh if we
were very bold we would send an
international maritime nato task force
to patrol the international waters off
odessa that would be a statement to
russia to say we are now taking this
seriously we're going to stand up to you
i mean nato of course one supranational
organization another is the united
nations and yeah russia has been ejected
from the u.n human rights council but if
you look at the vote there
24 countries voted against 58 countries
abstained we've heard an awful lot in
the past couple of weeks about a unity
of purpose with those opposed to what is
happening in ukraine you look at the
figures on a vote like that and that
that kind of unity of purpose doesn't
seem quite as clear
yes and you're absolutely right to point
to that the success of the sanctions
that will take a while to buy it is the
fact that the entire international
community
has lent into that but that vote itself
did expose many people that continue to
sit on the fence people like south
africa
brazil india and so forth we need to
work with these countries to make them
understand that this is against putin
against the regime not against the
russian people the more countries can
stay united on this the faster that
we're about to move and support ukraine
so it was an eye-opener and it shows
that there's much work to be done by the
international community not east britain
and the united states
we've just been looking at pictures em
from borodyanca and of course that we
heard from president zielinski yesterday
responding to the the accusations of war
crimes that have taken place in butcher
that we could see even worse
even worse there if such a thing is
imaginable just though in terms of the
process of securing a declaration of war
crimes having been committed
given that russia will give russia's
disdain for the international criminal
court
what prospect is there
well it's not just the disdain in the
international criminal court they left
it in 2016.
so i don't think there's any chance of
getting putin or indeed even a general
let alone a soldier uh to turn up in the
hague any time soon that shouldn't stop
us from collecting that evidence but we
need to think of what new vehicle needs
to be created to be able to hold these
people uh to account because it begs the
questions about our international rules
based order the reason why both russia
and to some extent china exam are able
to exploit our international rules it's
become they've become so rickety they've
become rather wobbly after you know 50
70 years since they were created after
the second world war the fact that china
and russia has a veto at the united
nations security council shows how
impotent these organizations have become
yet we now see state on state warfare
take place in europe there's a lot of
rebuilding to be done
sure but isn't it almost even even
simpler than that we heard from vladimir
putin's you know press
secretary yesterday the same as we've
heard from their ambassador to the
united united nations when the evidence
is put in front of the russians clear
compelling evidence prima facie evidence
of war crimes they just say no we didn't
do it and and in circumstances like that
we have to be concerned about their own
limits on their behavior don't we
yes and again this is what's been
exposed by this war is putin's disregard
for um russian life itself he doesn't
care about the soldiers that he loses
he's considering the legacy that he's
trying to create here he wants to expand
russian influence in the slavic arena of
europe which is why i'm afraid the penny
still hasn't dropped that this isn't
just about ukraine that we continue to
bench nate the nato forces the most
formidable alliance in the world as we
watch these activities these atrocities
take place in ukraine it begs the
question what scale of atrocity what
scale of war crime what scale of breach
of geneva convention must we witness
before we actually up our grain up our
game and actually move in to support the
ukrainian people in the way that they've
requested
um mr elwood what we have here i i do
want to ask you about um rishi sunak and
and his wife's non-dom tax status i i i
just wonder i mean i i saw someone
quoted in in the guardian this morning
tory mp but admittedly one that was
described as a friend of boris johnson
saying look if rishi sunak is as rich as
he is richer than increases to have his
wife having non-dom tax status at a time
that he's putting up taxis is a bad look
i'm just wondering your view on that
every minister when you enter uh
government has to make a declaration and
that declaration is confirmed to be
legal before you can take up the post so
there's nothing illegal about what's
been done by the chancellor whatsoever
if they're a bigger more fundamental
questions about the the existence and
the of the non-dom status that is
something for us as a country perhaps in
a deep parliament to debate but the idea
that we focus on this discussion about
uh
following the rules that actually exist
at the moment i think it's a distraction
for what we need to be focusing on which
is the previous subject right now of
what britain is going to do to help and
lead other countries support ukraine
yeah i i i do get the point that there
are there are certainly bigger topics
around than than rishi soon at the same
time you know the conservative party
have been in power since 2010. lord
ashcroft had to give up his non-dom
status so that he could sit in the house
and continue to sit in the house of
lords i mean this has been something
that has been circling around tory ranks
for quite some time
right and there again you go back to my
point the rules are there if the rules
as a whole need to be changed let's have
that debate but that's away from rishi
sunak's wife that's more to do with the
uh the existence the continuation of the
non-stone status and and the privileges
that you gain from that in my view they
are out of date they do need to be
reviewed
to myself always good to have you on the
show thanks for joining us
thank
ah you as we've just been hearing
questions of course around the tax
affairs of the chancellor's family not
going away rushing out defending his
wife's non-dom status in an interview in
the sun rob powell is back and you might
notice with his leg good to have you in
the studio you managed to make it in um
let's talk about the the interview that
rishi sunak has given to the santa
tatari call over there he's it's quite
emotional in parts i mean in essence he
is accusing
labour let's be honest let's be honest
about it he's accusing labour of using
his wife to get to him yeah he's come
out swinging he said this is a smear
campaign um against his wife that
essentially they are trying to
politically smear him by going sort of
via the root of his wife and her
finances and says she's a private
citizen and it essentially shouldn't
matter
what she does of course the the
background to this in terms of this
latest individual revelation anyway is
as you say that um rishi sunak's wife
claims non-dom status she is an indian
citizen
but
she has essentially said that her
permanent home is not in the uk so she
doesn't have to pay uk tax on earnings
that are gained overseas and clearly
that
is a potentially significant amount of
money given that she's the daughter of
an i.t billionaire and has shares
potentially significance
yeah reportedly worth millions now rishi
sunak has spoken to the sun uh this
morning what he has said is that every
single penny she earns in the uk she
pays uk taxes on and every penny that
she earns internationally for example in
india she would pay the full taxes on
that to smear my wife to get at me is
awful if she was living here and didn't
just happen to be married to me this
obviously would not be at all relevant
now i guess the case for the defense is
sort of what tobias elwood was setting
out there that there's no suggestion
she's done anything illegal uh no no one
or very few people at least pay any more
tax than they need to
so if we don't like the fact that she
has non-dom status then the problem
isn't with her claiming it it's with the
rules so you should change the rules
rather than attack i mean who would
change the rules though i mean
presumably the people that are sitting
in government including the chancellor
rishi tsunami yeah yeah well yeah it
would obviously be for the government to
do that but i think by focusing on the
issue of non-doms and
changing the policy around that i think
it misses a broader important political
point about the chancellor that feeds
into a broader story that's been brewing
for a number of months now that at a
time when he is pushing through quite
controversial and difficult to stomach
tax rises
is it made more difficult for
conservatives to justify that with a
chancellor that is quite this wealthy
and at a time where there's a cost of
living crunch where people are choosing
between heating and eating
this does raise questions about whether
someone that is this rich can truly
empathize with people that are
struggling with these sorts of issues
and in the context that we're living
through at the moment that really really
matters guys rob thank you
uh let's take you through the morning's
front pages uh beginning with the metro
human rights pariah the headline in that
particular paper
after the united nations voted to strip
russia of its place on the un human
rights council
on the financial times reports that a
russian aluminium company has become the
first group within the country
to call for inquiries into alleged war
crimes in the ukrainian time of butcher
the tax affairs of the wife of
chancellor rishi sunak they are the lead
story in the telegraph allies of the
sunax claiming that number 10 is trying
to undermine him
and that story also leads in the
guardian but says she may have avoided
up to 20 million pounds in tax in the uk
meanwhile the mirror alleges that the uk
has actually given her 50 million pounds
in the form of public sector contracts
to an indian-based firm that she partly
owns
but as we were just discussing with uh
with rob the son has an interview with
the chancellor at their headline
lay off my misses
at least two people have died after a
shooting in a crowded part of central
tel aviv skies alistar bunco is there
for us this morning alistair good to see
you just bring us up to date with the
latest at least two people dead
yeah two people dead this is the fourth
uh terrorist attack in israel in the
last couple of weeks and particularly
concerning that it took place in central
tel aviv in a street
which has got a number of bars
restaurants people out drinking and the
gunman struck and what then happened was
a manhunt to try and find him that went
on until the early hours of this morning
he was eventually located in
neighbouring jaffa
and police after a firefight shot him
dead but things that were already i mean
it was already very tense here anyway
now that we're in the ramadan period
ramadan festival
this will make it even more so
here in jerusalem today preparing for
the first friday prayers in ramadan
many of the main roads have been shut
down by police there are scores and
scores of soldiers and armed police uh
patrolling the city because there's a
real fear that the tensions are bubbling
and there could be a repeat of the
conflict that we saw last year and so
the israeli government is trying to do
anything it can to avoid that but these
terror attacks make citizens feel
far
very very unsafe but they also add to
the divisions here uh that could very
easily spill over
alastair thank you
that's still to come on the program
at half-past seven with diplomatic
efforts to weaken russia's assault all
ukraine continue i'll be speaking with a
former nato policy chief about what more
can be done to hamstring putin's
campaign
and shortly afterwards i'll be joined by
a french journalist and commentator as
the country prepares to go to the polls
in the first round of presidential
elections
at just after eight o'clock the shadow
attorney general emily thornberry joins
us in the studio to react to the latest
developments at home and abroad
but before all that let's take a look at
some of the other stories at making the
rundown this morning and drivers are
being warned to expect long delays next
weekend as millions of people embark on
an easter getaway the aaa estimates that
more than 27 million car journeys are
planned between good friday and easter
monday in dover the district council has
said it's prepared to declare a major
incident if traffic disruption around
the town continues
the prime minister is set to meet the
german chancellor olaf schultz at
downing street today boris johnson
expected to offer assistance to berlin
in their bids to ease dependency on
russian oil and gas
the academy board of governors at the
oscars will meet today to discuss the
consequences for will smith following
his slapping of the comedian chris rock
during the 94th academy awards smith
officially resigning from the academy
last week adding that he was prepared to
fully accept any and all consequences
for his behavior will those involved the
removal of the oscar that is something
we will be discussing with an
entertainment journalist a little bit
later on in the programme
but now thousands have been told to
evacuate their homes after heavy
rainfall and flooding hit parts of
australia's east coast in sydney nearly
a month's rain fell in one night let's
head to sydney where wisconsin's
australian reporter nicola johnson has
been experiencing the floods first hand
nicola good to see you well i see you've
actually managed to find yourself a bit
of dry land
it's something of a premium where you
are i suspect
that's right we're standing in front of
the nepean river this is one of the
major rivers on the outskirts of sydney
you can see just how swollen this river
is and
just how high it has been now this is
the second time
the river has flooded
in a month and i think our cameraman is
showing you some of the debris on top of
the light showing just how high it was
earlier it hasn't risen as high this
time
but a couple of hours ago we were in one
of the neighboring
uh towns of camden on the outskirts of
sydney it has flooded
three times in a month and this is what
we're seeing
all across the east coast of new south
wales it's meant to be summer here it
isn't meant to be pouring with rain and
floods
but from byron bay lismore central coast
sydney and south coast town after town
as well as the city of sydney is seeing
flash flooding
swollen rivers and serious landslides
nicole many thanks indeed
time for us to see how the weather's
looking domestically
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
today lighter winds and fewer showers
than recently the weekend looking mainly
fine it's a frosty start for many of us
but cloud over southern england has kept
the temperatures up there largely dry
some wintry showers around especially
over northern scotland the rain in the
far southwest will spread eastwards
during the morning clipping channel
coastal areas along the way elsewhere
it'll stay mainly dry with sunny spells
but showers will develop more widely
a reminder of our top stories and a
kremlin spokesman has told sky news that
russian forces have suffered significant
losses in the war in ukraine but denied
accusations of war crimes
ukraine's president has described the
scenes
in the town all bodies
foreign surrounding his wife's tax
status calling them
unpleasant smears
[Music]
uh well in the last half an hour the
chair of the defence select committee
has suggested that nato needs to go
further in the face of russian
aggression against ukraine tobias elwood
told me the organization needs to do
more to ensure ukrainians win the war
not just avoid defeat
we've been too easily spooked by the
kremlin rhetoric britain has done more i
have to say than most other countries
than i think in nearly every other
country firstly prior to the invasion
and then after the invasion as well but
because nato itself won't give the
blessing won't endorse uh greater
hardware to be put in we're now seeing a
public bidding war between between
countries we're doing enough right now
to ensure that ukraine doesn't lose but
not enough to ensure that they win
uh and rob is back with us once again in
the studio let's focus shall we on or
what what more can be done because of
course the the complaint has always been
if we do more we risk being dragged in
as a third party to a war rather than
someone standing on the sidelines but
the pressure particularly when you see
what we have all seen coming from places
like butcher on the prime minister's is
pretty big yeah tobias always been
someone that's been sounding the alarm
about this sort of threat for a while
has been unhappy with policy towards
russia even before the first tank
started rolling into ukraine as you
suggest though the balance that western
leaders have to make is at what point do
you start providing ukraine with such
heavy armaments that it feels like it
sort of crosses that line into too much
of a even image or vision of kind of
direct conflict between nato members
western countries
and russia now as it happens the prime
minister is meeting with the german
chancellor olaf schultz today and
there's multiple reports in papers this
morning about potentially new
announcements for um heavier weapons and
more weapons to be put into ukraine but
of course another part of this which you
imagine would come up in those talks
between the prime minister um and the
german chancellor um is on this question
of energy we had the energy strategy
here in the uk yesterday part of which
aim was to try and make the uk more
independent in terms of producing our
own energy so we're less dependent on
other countries on the continent
in europe clearly reliance on russian
energy is more of an issue and we have
seen that tension really between
the uk and the us and the eu in terms of
pulling back the amount of energy they
buy from russia because the argument is
essentially that whilst uh buying this
energy of russia you're giving money to
them to fund the war in ukraine so it is
self-defeating but of course
pulling back from buying russian energy
on the continent would have other
impacts not least on residents that are
trying to pay their bills on the
constant now as well certainly but rob
for now thank you
well after another week of diplomacy
let's get the latest on the west's
efforts to try and slow russian progress
in ukraine uh let's speak now to fabrice
pottier former director of policy
planning at nato joins us on the
programme february great to have you and
your expertise with us this morning and
you you might just have heard me talking
to rob powell our political
correspondent about that which we heard
from from tobias elwood chair of the
defence select committee here but also a
former military man himself his argument
is that nato cannon should be doing an
awful lot more
is that possible
it's possible and it's necessary because
the choice here is whether we are
entering
a war on the very long haul a war of
attrition
uh with entire cities in the in the
donbas in eastern ukraine being
basically wiped out
and and cbd is obviously killed by by
the thousands
or whether we are trying to help
zilenski finish this war on terms that
are actually acceptable to him and the
ukrainian population
well the argument made by mr elwood and
others is that in the past the west has
been too fearful has has stayed back has
stepped away uh for fear of annoying
russia angering russia pushing russia
into further military conflict given
what we have seen in butcher given what
president zielenski is suggesting we may
well soon see emerging from borrowed
yanka and other places it it does rather
feel that there's not much more that the
russians can do to surprises in terms of
their military activity
dota underestimated capacity for
destruction and and i think what you
have seen in mario paul is a strategy
reminiscent of the stunning times of
basically emptying entire ukrainian
cities and population center of their
very substance with deportation with
mass bombing so i i i think we have to
hold our breath and and for what's
coming and this is why
tobias is right we need to provide much
more much more quickly because now time
is of the essence and and i think this
line that your correspondent was talking
about between what is acceptable weapon
supply and what is more sensitive this
line is also the one we draw it's not
just to let putin always draw the line
and those red lines so i think it's also
time for us to be more forward leaning
and more willing to to really really
help zelensky finish
the job again on acceptable terms where
he can have a functioning country after
the war
and families i don't know if you're
aware but yesterday my colleague mark
austin um had an interview a long
interview with vladimir putin's
spokesman dmitry pescov you're aware of
that and i suppose it was interesting
and intriguing for a variety of reasons
once again we had the defense which was
no we didn't do it despite the
overwhelming evidence but perhaps even
more interestingly we did get a
concession from the russians that they
have endured significant losses which
perhaps is as far as they've gone so far
is that simply because the evidence of
their losses is just so overwhelming now
i i think there's probably a double
meaning here one on one hand you're
right
the dead russian soldiers have to come
back home even though they have held
many of them actually they have left
many of them uh in ukraine on the ground
uh or they have kept them in belarus
basically away from the russian
population because they know the
political sensitiveness of basically
russian body bags uh that's one thing
the second thing i think there's also
this this kind of putting narrative of
of idolizing violence and the sacrifice
of violence and that the special
operation requires special sacrifices
and clearly he's saying that to his
population on the economic sanction and
now they seem to be developing that
narrative that yes there are many
soldiers who die but it's worth it so
never underestimate the kremlin capacity
to turn something terrible in actually a
kind of positive narrative to sustain
the propaganda
nato of course seemingly speaking with
one voice at the moment it doesn't feel
like that way when it comes of course to
the other international organization the
united nations we know of course that
russia has now been
barred from sitting on the u.n human
rights council but you look at the vote
24 countries voted against 58 abstained
i mean
other perhaps cracks in the
international consensus or or the view
of there actually being an international
consensus against russia's actions in
ukraine
i i don't think there are cracks i think
there are there are sides and they are
this kind of gray zone of some countries
who are not necessarily explicitly and
actively supporting the russian war
effort but you don't want either to
support uh the the ukrainians and the
western efforts uh and and i think
russia is trying to amplify that grey
zone to show that they are not alone but
the reality is that they were also
you might recall few weeks ago a vote by
the general assembly and only five
countries were on russia's side and an
overwhelming majority of the
un members voted to actually condemn the
russian illegal war in ukraine so i i
think there is this clear uh choice here
but again there is a gray zone of those
who don't necessarily want to go all the
way
we've heard from uh uh from the mayor of
of kiev vladimir klitschko at vitaly
cluster i should say um that the life in
parts of kiev is is almost returning to
normal the russians have withdrawn to
such an extent that shops businesses are
opening up their remains a curfew that
situation might not last for very long
we should expect the russians to to
redouble their efforts in parts of the
country where they where they have been
pushed back
yes exactly i think the strategy is
clearly of a redeployment after having
failed the original goal of the of the
operation which was to
decapitate kiev both literally and
figuratively
but the risk here is again a war of
attrition uh of more static kind of
heavy artillery bombardment uh and the
risk politically is that basically putin
is sitting on the long haul and is not
going to let zelensky have a functional
territory and a functional country that
can move on from the war that has been
the strategy since 2014 it's the same
strategy in moldova with the presence of
uh russian troops
the russians are very sticky of power
and once they they invade the place they
rarely move out or they kind of stay
with some proxies and i think this is
the
the very risky scenario and this is why
tobias ellwood is right that we need to
really give everything every military
hardware for the ukrainians to try to
finish and push the russian out of
ukraine
well let's see what nato does next step
fabrice pottier great to have you on the
show this morning thanks very much
on sunday france heads to the polls with
the race to be the next president
tightening emmanuel macron's lead has
dwindled over the past few weeks with
support growing for opponents from both
the far right and the far left joining
is now in the programme and elizabeth
moote french journalist and political
commentator and elizabeth great to have
you on the program this morning um for
those of us not entirely of a with the
french presidential election system this
is about the first round this weekend
and and it does rather feel that
emmanuel macron is facing pressure as
we've already mentioned from both the
far right and the far left
uh he is facing pressure he has lost
six points uh for this first round in
three weeks and he seems to have lost
his momentum and the highest he's been
uh we have 12 candidates in the first
round we will have two candidates the
ones that come first and second in the
second round in two weeks time but uh
emmanuel macron has always been leading
and he went back he went up as much as
30 percent in the first round on his own
he's now down to 24 or in samples 23
whereas marine le pen
is between 21
and 22 and so uh they're getting very
very very close uh in a configuration
that nobody expected uh
two three weeks ago emmanuel macron was
still benefiting from the statesman
effect and all his attempts to um to
handle and to to to bring peace to the
ukraine crisis that's completely done
and in the meantime he has done no
campaign
uh he gave a single rally um uh last
week uh in paris and there's a feeling
that he doesn't bother to do it and uh
it gives an a an appearance of contempt
for the voters he's trying to fight this
back but he's got one day today we're
not allowed to campaign tomorrow and the
first round is on sunday
it's a chunk of the reason that
president macron is having such
difficulty at the moment due to
to my eyes alarming levels of voter
apathy in france i saw estimates that
perhaps as high as 31 percent might be
avoiding voting this weekend
it's possible but um it's a little more
than usual but the other thing is that
the choice that there may be 12
candidates uh for for
this sunday uh but many of the voters
feel that this is no choice and uh they
don't really want to bother because they
don't like any of them they're not
pleased with any of them there is a very
obvious rejection of the president uh
he's got a hardcore of a faithful and
there are increasingly people who say we
have to vote for him even though um he's
not our favorite but
uh otherwise we'll get and then they
usually say marine le pen or they say
the hard left chest who's been doing
very well jean-luc
and so this is not an enthusiasm for a
new project as it was five years ago it
really is we don't like the others what
do we do now which is exactly the kind
of configuration when people make up
their minds at the last minute uh
more than half voters uh have still said
that they are not entirely sure not a
hundred percent of who they would cast
their ballot for in on sunday uh next
sunday
but but just in terms of of marine le
pen if as many expect she makes it
through to the next round we see a
runoff between macron and le pen i mean
we could be talking a difference of of
single digit percentage points couldn't
we in terms of the support at that
ballot i mean even if macron wins marine
le pen could win in a sense by coming so
close to the keys to the elysee
i think
unless she has been hugely overestimated
i think that's exactly what we're
looking at
uh and this is she's she's in in some
style she has been incredibly favored by
the existence of an even harder right
candidate than she is that's erik zimmer
the luffy young columnist who suddenly
sort of waged a sort of anna trump
campaign he's very unlike trump but the
campaign was a bit like trump's campaign
uh uh in 2016. and people were
fascinated by him he had by by far the
largest attended rallies uh the one
before last was 100 000 people in paris
there's been another one in paris
yesterday uh and um even though people
especially with his reaction to ukraine
which was
extremely muted and refusing to accept
ukrainian refugees that was a complete
disaster for his momentum but even with
that he has managed to make marine le
pen by contrast
to look uh reasonably mild and harmless
and that's probably the best that can
happen because right now le president is
not very popular
uh and it was a bit it looks like a
wonderful morning in paris we'll let you
go off and enjoy and elizabeth mitty
thank you for joining us
now it might not be quite in the
circumstances that fans had hoped for
but pink floyd most of them anyway are
back after more than three decades let's
have a listen
[Music]
a new track with ukrainian singer andrei
kivlich who left his tour in the u.s and
federally to return home and fight in
ukraine it is the first song that pink
floyd has recorded since 1994 is the
division bell all to raise funds for
ukrainian humanitarian relief
time for the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
lighter winds and fewer showers today
than recently the weekend looking mainly
fine it is a frosty start for many of us
but cloud over southern england has kept
the temperatures up there largely dry
but there are some wintry showers around
especially over northern scotland icy
stretches are likely the rain in the far
south west will spread eastwards during
the morning clipping channel coastal
areas along the way elsewhere it will
stay mainly dry with sunny spells but
showers will develop more widely they'll
be most frequent over northern scotland
northern ireland and donegal with some
wintriness on the hills cold again but
not as windy as yesterday